Joe Biden's border crisis not a big deal
to Democrats in the same week we saw a
horde of migrants rushing a Port of
Entry house Dems skipped out on a field
hearing held at the southern border and
our accusing Republicans have planned
politics GOP lawmakers are calling out
the Malarkey Malarkey now this was
supposed to be a full committee but as
you can see the Democrats are not here
they decided to not to not show why
well they said coming here was just a
political stunt the thing I'm most
distraught about
there's not a Democrat here
this is American issue it's appalling
that the Democrats didn't show up in
America is under attack a lot of people
described what was happening here in
South Texas as a humanitarian crisis a
border crisis and I was very candid and
I said that I think we have a bit of a
policy crisis
Democrats claim it was just too far
no because it's far Texas people at home
are clapping two of them Democrats claim
they never agreed to attend in the first
place but our guy at the border with the
great hair says Dems booked their travel
and had a witness list before backing
out here's the reality Democrats missed
you heard the secretary he said we have
operational control that's the
definition of based upon the definition
you have sir up there no we don't have
operational control no sir we are more
25 times more likely to have an overdose
death in the United States than we are
in Mexico we have a fentanyl problem
and we need to fix it
Dana they booked traveled and pulled out
uh they've done this before yeah they
did it too like two weeks ago in Yuma
Arizona they decided not to go to that
hearing anyway so this is not this is
not a last minute oh my gosh they want
to do a political stunt this is a
strategy for them to totally avoid the
issue and also I didn't know it was an
option not to go to work yeah is that an
option can I could we just like don't
show up tomorrow because I do that once
in a while yeah you do I only want this
on
um
the other thing is they had asked for a
witness that witness was going to
testify the other thing that's what I
can't believe tomorrow we'll probably
read the New York Times all the
Democrats are worried about their losing
with blue collar workers they're losing
with people on the border they're losing
in red America well why because you
don't show up you pretend like it's not
a problem also the White House has
turned to this talking point I mentioned
in the last block that it's actually all
the Republicans fault that this is
happening and people can see it with
their own eyes if that's not true
Jessica why is there just one honest
Democrat perhaps one at this table who
might just say we don't care like why so
why try so hard to say that you care
about the border and not do anything why
not just free yourself and go you know
what we don't care we never cared we
want no borders we think it's great it's
great for labor it's great for getting
new blood if you say that then you know
we should move on set you free yes
here's your opportunity I appreciate
that I'm going to decline today because
it's not my reality there are Democrats
who think that there should be no
borders right that's not the bulk of the
party though and everybody who's being
honest about this knows what happens
which is either side doesn't want to do
the other side's thing even if it's
something that's objectively important
now I don't have
a lot of people at least that I speak to
on the Democratic side who say that this
is a top issue for them but it's
something that matters obviously no one
wants to be losing American lives to
fentanyl no one wants these kind of
crises we've talked about over the
summer the I think it was 52 migrants
died in the back of that truck there
were a couple of boats
um that got into an accident I think
eight people died from that those flat
out humanitarian crises how families are
living at the border what's going on in
terms of those camps all those are good
things when you show up good things
happen period either you learn something
or you could have a good moment and
we've seen that already in a few of the
hearings that have already taken place
back in D.C Democrats have gotten a lot
of good moments in there where they've
had Customs and Border Patrol officials
people working down on the border there
where they've said things like has the
Biden Administration made it a policy
that we shouldn't enforce the law here
and then they have to say absolutely not
that isn't what's going on here and then
they get their point and then the
Republicans go and they get their point
so
it's an unfortunate game because it has
such dire implications and I think
that's showing up you can do your own
press Gaggle there and you can get it
out to your people just just go just go
Jesse
I hate math and if my math teacher said
we're going to have a field trip today
I would go anywhere right because you
just want to get out of the classroom
yeah this is a field hearing how often
in Congress do you get a field hearing
yeah go down put up with whatever the
Republicans are up to and then go out to
dinner and have some Mexican food and
then have a cerveza and then fly back
with your team and then hold a press
conference and say the Republicans stink
how hard is that right how dare you how
dare you Jessica how dare you you say
Republicans is this an artificial stance
don't show up to your stuff you know you
don't like people don't like going to
their stuff we always go to your stupid
hearings about climate about gender
about January 6th how many times yeah we
tried to put people in the committee
that we wanted and you wouldn't let us
go oh election deniers are not people
that you want on the January
[Music]
the point is
How come every time things get a little
tough you guys fly The Coop remember all
your little state legislators they
always leave remember there's like some
big vote in a in a state legislature you
guys always fly somewhere else you can't
do your job now if I was a Democrat and
my representatives were always leaving
the scene of a crime because they want
to get their hands dirty they don't want
to like take any blame I'd be mad and
I'm tired of your cheap tactics it's
like football
great analogy permission not needed you
guys are so dirty you're always spying
and cheating and stealing and then when
we try to do something tough like boot
someone off of committee you guys weep
now and and the refs should be throwing
flags on both teams but they only throw
Flags when we do stuff and you guys are
out there going for people's knees eye
gouging taking shots to the head I'm
tired of it Republicans have to start
playing dirty next hearing that we don't
like we're not showing wait a minute
last week I sent you don't you think we
should play dirty and you said no
because we're not like that when they go
low we go lower oh well okay
okay yeah that's a good point all right
let me tell you what I think okay if you
want to ask me what I think here's the
thing they run the homeland security
committee it's their job to show up it's
their jurisdiction it's their committee
it's their country and it's their job
and they have the nerve to not show up
you're right it's like not going to work
but they're not even hiding it they're
like like yeah we ain't going what are
you going to do about it but one of the
things that's so significant when I was
reading the papers today is that the
young there was a surge Across America
of young and unaffiliated Latino voters
now Latino voters so it is the first
time Latino voters are outpacing
non-latino voters on the verge of
becoming the number one biggest swing
voter groups in the United States so now
we're gonna everybody's gonna have to
deal with the fact that the Affiliated
Latino voters now represent the largest
percentage of Latino voters in Florida
now and the number of Latinos was 62
million in 2020 a 23 increase in a
decade what does that tell you it tells
you you need to show up at things like
this whether you think it's your job or
not because you're all about politics
and ideology and there's a whole sector
of this country that's brand new and
waiting to be plucked welcome there you
go watch your mouth yeah
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else